Fashion used to be sold in four seasons.
Zara wants you to buy for 104.
New clothes arrive in every store twice a week...
...days known by fans as "Z Days."
Customers visit Zara on average six times more often than its competitors...
...causing rival stores to dread its arrival on their turf.
When Zara opened a store in China last year,...
...one industry commentator noted, "It just murdered everything around it."
And when the doors of Zara's first Australian store opened in Sydney in April,...
...80% of the stock was snapped up within three minutes.
Shoppers might love Zara but fashion's elite are not so happy.
One unnamed designer complained...
..."we spend a fortune researching and working up ideas,...
...then Zara comes along and walks off with them for nothing."
Zara has achieved global success with almost zero advertising...
...which its founder calls a "pointless distraction."
Zara: fast, affordable, pre-packaged fashion.
A business built on speed.
Designed for addiction.